and we call it the ipad
and what this device does is
extraordinary
it's unbelievably great way better than
a laptop
steve jobs said those words nine years
ago when he introduced the original ipad
and for the past 9 years that hasn't
really been true
ipads have always been limited and you
could do so much more with the laptop
but now in 2019 steve jobs statement is
finally coming true
this is all due to the combination of
two things the extremely powerful
and capable ipad pro that is finally
equipped with the usb-c
port and the upcoming release of ipad os
apple's brand new operating system
that's exclusively for ipads
adding a lot of computer-like
functionality these two things together
are able to satisfy the most common
computer needs that people have today
and as you'll see in a minute the ipad
pro packs a ton of performance and in
some ways
offers even more than you can get with a
macbook we currently have a couple of
options when looking for our lower end
premium apple computer
we've got the 2018 ipad pro starting at
800
for the 11 inch or a thousand dollars
for the 12.9 inch
we've also got the 2019 macbook air for
eleven hundred dollars
and the 2019 13 inch macbook pro for
thirteen hundred dollars
and this year's base macbook pro is a
really great value for the cash
as you guys have probably seen in our
recent which macbook should you buy
video
but what's great about the ipad pro is
that even if you go all out and load up
the larger 12.9 inch model
with 256 gigs of storage apple's new and
improved smart keyboard
and the second generation apple pencil
it still comes out cheaper than the 13
inch macbook pro
with a matching 256 gigs of storage and
even better
if you don't need some of those things
like the larger display the apple pencil
or the smart keyboard
you can pick and choose exactly what you
want and save even more cash
now the point of this video is seeing if
the ipad pro can actually be a better
choice for some people
instead of going for a more expensive
macbook as well as seeing what
advantages you get with either one
for starters a lot of people think that
macbooks will perform better
because they're obviously much larger
and thicker machines so we ran geekbench
4
a cross-platform benchmark that tests
raw performance and we found that the
800
ipad pro performs better than both
macbooks in both single
and multi-core tasks which is absolutely
incredible for the price
we then tested the graphics performance
with geekbench 4's metal test
and we were shocked to see that the ipad
pro got a higher score than even the
1800
2019 macbook pro and all these macbooks
came out very recently
the crazy thing to think about is that
the ipad pro is about to get
even more powerful with the expected
ipad pro update coming this fall
which should be packing a new a13x
mobile chip
and with having that much power packed
into a thin and light device like the
ipad pro
it would definitely be a great idea to
protect your investment
with an incredibly affordable warranty
from upsee our sponsor for this video
upsy works with nationwide certified
repair shops and helps buyers in the
united
states save up to 70 percent on a
warranty
compared to retailers and you can buy it
within 60 days after your ipad purchase
or 45 days for smartphones upsy makes it
incredibly easy to make a claim by
having real people
available on the phone 24 7 365 days a
year
and they store your receipt and all the
info you'll need right in your upc
account
you can use the link in the video
description with the code maxtec today
for 10 off your first warranty purchase
so back to the ipad pro
even with the 2018 model it's definitely
not a slouch compared to the macbook
yes it does have only 4 gigabytes of ram
compared to 8 gigabytes
or even 16 for an extra 200 on those
lower end macbooks but ios has always
been optimized for low amounts of ram
and basically every app out there still
works flawlessly
we can easily see two major markets
where the ipad pro makes sense to buy
instead of a laptop
and before we get into that let's first
discuss the perks of each
starting with the macbook of course you
get a full built-in keyboard and a
trackpad with full cursor support
so you get a more traditional and
comfortable laptop feel you also get an
extra port on the macbook
or three 3x reports if you're willing to
spend at least 1800
and they're much faster ports as well
supporting thunderbolt 3 so you can do
much more with them
and the biggest advantage is mac os
which has a lot more flexibility
multitasking is much better on mac os
and same with connecting and using
external devices and drives
there's just so much more you can do
with mac os especially using full
desktop productivity apps
like final cut pro lightroom xcode and
photoshop and finally the speakers are
quite a bit better
so here's a quick sound comparison so
you can hear the differences
[Music]
while the macbook speakers are
noticeably better the ipad pro is the
only ipad
to come with two speakers on each side
so you get true stereo sound and now
let's discuss the advantages of the ipad
pro
for starters it's much more portable
than any macbook it's smaller
thinner and much lighter so it's easy to
carry around another perk is that you
have the choice of buying a keyboard
like apple's smart keyboard folio
which also acts as a protective case for
both the back and the front of the ipad
and while the keys aren't as nice to
type on at least you don't have to worry
about failed keys like with the
butterfly keyboards on the max
and in the worst case scenario if the
smart keyboard somehow breaks
you can easily swap it out for a new one
or buy one of the many bluetooth
keyboard options
like the bridge pro keyboard now that's
something you can't do on a macbook
and when you're not using the keyboard
you can easily flip it to the backside
and use the ipad in tablet mode
and that's another benefit you have a
touchscreen display with the ipad
that's very simple and intuitive to use
which currently isn't available on
any mac and the ipad pro's display is
many many times better than
any macbook display you have higher
pixel density for a sharper image
you have a brighter 600 nit display
compared to 500 on the macbook pro
so you can actually watch hdr content
not only that but it's still just as
color accurate with p3 wide color gamut
support
and finally it gets pro motion
technology which dynamically adjusts the
display's refresh rate between
24 and 120 hertz for super smooth
animations and navigation
while every single mac display is
currently limited to 60 hertz
while the macbooks get touch id for
quick login and authentication
the ipad pro now has face id which is
completely hidden in the bezels
so it's really convenient another
advantage is that you can get an ipad
pro with lte cellular service
allowing you to have internet make calls
and text people while away from wi-fi
that's something that's not possible on
a macbook the ipad pro also gets a
rear-facing camera
something that you obviously don't get
on a macbook and not just any camera
it's a top of the line camera from the
latest iphones with 12 megapixel photos
and 4k video recording at 60fps
the ipad pro also has a 7 megapixel
front-facing camera
that completely wipes the floor with the
720p camera on the macbooks
just check out this video and microphone
comparison between them this is a video
and audio quality test on the 2019
macbook air
this is a video and audio quality test
on the 2018 macbook pro
this is an audio and video quality test
on the 2018 ipad pro
one thing that you can't get on a
macbook is a stylus and the apple pencil
is the best
out there you can use it to draw take
notes and quickly mark up documents and
screenshots
and even with the incredible performance
that you get on the ipad pro
it's still rated for the same 10 hours
of battery life
and that's with a battery that's twice
as small as the one on the macbook pro
and since the seven nanometer processor
uses less power
you'll probably get even better battery
life while doing power demanding tasks
like video editing even better the ipad
pro is completely fanless
so you never have to worry about any fan
noise at all and finally there's the new
ipad os
which adds a bunch of computer-like
features like updated multitasking
new gestures and automatic desktop mode
in safari
but the biggest advantage is having
access to the ios app store there are
undoubtedly many
many times more apps on the ios app
store compared to mac os
and most developers are continuing to
make apps for ios
instead of mac os you also have lots of
alternatives for productivity apps like
video and photo editing apps and much
more
and if we take a look at gaming there
are countless amounts of games available
on ios
while the game selection on mac os is
pretty much non-existent
with that said here are the two major
markets where it makes sense to buy an
ipad pro
over a macbook the first major market is
students
who i'm sure would much rather carry
around a one pound ipad in their
backpack
instead of a much larger three pound
macbook with the apple pencil
students can easily take notes markup
documents and easily share them with the
ipad
which is a major benefit compared to a
macbook and with a smart keyboard folio
they can use it in class just like a
laptop and it's great because ipad os
has finally added full keyboard shortcut
support for typing documents and using
in safari ipad os
has also finally added local storage and
external drive support
so they can easily hook up a flash drive
and transfer their school work and files
to
and from their ipad now external storage
support is definitely not as full
featured and flexible as on mac os
but it offers just enough functionality
for what students need it for
there's also a high quality rear-facing
camera so students can quickly and
easily snap a photo of their professor's
chalkboard or powerpoint presentation
slide for future studying
not only that but with external display
mirroring support
a student could even connect their ipad
pro to projector to present their
slideshow to their class
without having to use a laptop and if
they need the extra performance for
certain productivity apps or games
the ipad pro offers immense amounts of
power the display is also excellent and
the speakers are good enough to stream
netflix
or any other media they'd like the ipad
is basically going to become the new
standard computer for students
and finally the second major market for
choosing an ipad pro over a macbook
is the massive amount of people who just
need a basic computer
for common tasks there are people who
absolutely need a mac for doing things
like high-end video or photo editing
programming in xcode and audio
production in logic
pro but a good majority of people only
do basic computer tasks like browsing
the web
typing up and printing documents
transferring and storing files
using apps and maybe even playing some
games and with apple's upcoming ipad os
the ipad pro is going to do all these
things and it's going to do them well
and if you think about it if you take a
common person that might not be very
familiar with technology
when they pick up an ipad pro it's going
to feel natural to them
the touch ui is simple and more
importantly it's very familiar
because it's the same thing they're used
to on their iphone or smartphone
laptops like apple's low end macbook air
have been the standard for common people
who just need a basic reliable computer
and it still is even to this day because
the majority of people have no idea that
with ipad os
an ipad can now finally replace a laptop
so if this video has convinced you to
save some cash by going with an ipad pro
instead of a macbook we'll leave links
down below to the best sales on the 2018
ipad pro
and don't forget to protect your
investment with a warranty from upsc so
if this video helped you out make sure
to tap that like button
and click the circle above to subscribe
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video